STILL LOVE IT.
OKAY, CAN I JUST SAY."
WELL, THIS IS INTERESTING.
ACCORDING TO A NEW RESEARCH,
THE PANDEMIC MAY HAVE CHANGED
PEOPLE'S PERSONALITIES FOREVER
I'M NOT SURE I'VE NOTICED
ANYONE ACTING DIFFERENTLY.
WHAT ABOUT YOU, HIGGINS?
>> Steve: WOULDN'T KNOW ABOUT
THAT, JACK
ALWAYS BEEN THE SAME TICKET
FROM BACCARAT STEVE.
ALL BACCARAT EVER CARED ABOUT
WAS THE CLICK, CLICK, CLICKEDY
CLACK OF THE ROULETTE WHEEL.
SEE THOSE TRIPLE CHERRIES COME
UP ON MY FAVORITE SLOT MACHINE
AND SHOPLIFTING CRAB LEGS FROM
CIRCUS CIRCUS BUFFET
COME ON, LUCKY 4s.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> Jimmy: QUEST, HAVE YOU
NOTICED HIGGINS HAS BEEN ACTING
DIFFERENTLY?
♪
>> Questlove: I DON'T PAY MIND
TO ANYBODY BUT ME.
MY LEATHER JACKET AND MY HOG
SHE'S A '78 HARLEY, SILVER
HEAD, AND THERE'S NOTHING MORE
THAN I LOVE THAN LIFE THAN
WHIPPING HER DOWN THE
SOUTH DAKOTA PRAIRIE HITTING
80 MILES-PER-HOUR WHILE THE OLD
LADY SITS BEHIND AND FEEDS ME
MEATBALLS FROM OLIVE GARDEN.
♪
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> Jimmy: JAMES, DO YOU THINK
PEOPLE'S PERSONALITIES CHANGED
BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC?
>> YOU KNOW ME, JIMMY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I'VE ALWAYS BEEN THE SAME.
FAN OF ALL THINGS -- SCIENCE
FICTION AND GEEK CULTURE
I'M THE BIGGEST FAN OF "HOUSE
OF THE DRAGON.
[ LAUGHTER ]
THIS SIDE OF WESTEROS, LOL
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE
I'VE EVEN LEARNED THE LANGUAGE
SPOKEN BY THE ELVES ON THE
SHOW, HIGH VALYRIAN.
CHECK THIS OUT
[ LAUGHTER ]
[ SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH ]